welcome everybody we're starting today
with two stories that are going to upset
uh a bunch of people in my audience and
that's okay one is about jordan peterson
which we will get to the first is about
whoopi goldberg many of you wrote to me
about whoopi goldberg's statements on
the view where she is one of a number of
co-hosts about the holocaust and race
and jewish people
and as i was preparing a story about
this news broke that whoopi goldberg
indeed has now been suspended for two
weeks
by the view because of her comments
about the holocaust now
i'm just gonna give you my
interpretation of what she said and i'm
going to explain to you uh why what she
said is so problematic and what the main
thrust of what whoopi said on the view
is that the holocaust is not about race
or was not about race and there's really
two or three different layers of
confusion here which i'm going to try to
pick apart
and there's a ton of people who still
don't understand the concept
of judaism as a race
saying well hold up but judaism's a
religion it's not really a race and the
part that makes this segment difficult
is that unfortunately i mean listen i
expect out out and out anti-semitism
from the right i get it all the time
soros funds you go back to israel a
place i've been once and have no real
connection to um you know all these
different things i expect that from from
the right but on the left there's a
different thing that goes on and we saw
it with the women's march where for
example the women's march from from
several years ago now
they didn't want leadership didn't want
jewish women
involved on the board because jewish
women were seen as privileged whites
rather than a historically discriminated
minority group and in built in that are
all sorts of biases and prejudices that
only reinforce anti-semitic tropes and
so the left has a problem with this too
i don't care if you don't like hearing
that i'm going to call it out on both
sides so let's just jump into the clip
and i'm going to try rather than
pre-explain let's just look at this
piece by piece okay let's take a look
well also if you're going to do this
then let's be truthful about it because
the holocaust isn't about race
no
no it's not about racism
but it's it's not about race
it's not about race
because
it's about man's inhumanity to man
that's what it's about but it's about
white supremacy but it's not it's not
about ideologies
but these are two white groups of people
well how do we have to blame
them as white men but you're missing the
point you're missing the point the
minute you turn it into race it goes
down this alley let's talk about it for
what it is it's how people treat each
other
it's a problem it doesn't matter if
you're black or white because black
white jews
and of course it does matter if the
people carrying out the holocaust
believe they're doing it along racial
lines because they see jews as a
different race which we will get to it's
how everybody eats each other so is it
if you're uncomfortable if you hear
about mouse
should you be worried should your child
say oh my god
okay and then in another clip again she
says the holocaust is white people doing
stuff to white people and a tennessee
school pulled the graphic novel mouse
out of their lessons on the holocaust
because it contained
some nudity and some bad language
personally i'm shocked because you know
given
the story of mouse i'm i'm surprised
that that's what that's what made you
uncomfortable the fact that there was
some nudity and uh
i mean it's it's about the holocaust the
killing of six million people but that
didn't that didn't bother you but the
the naked i'm not sure that they don't
use the naked part
as a kind of a canard yeah to throw you
off from from the fact that they might
like history that makes white maybe they
look bad
well why this is why people do it into
wiping yeah so there is that same idea
white people doing it to white people so
here's the thing first of all
there's this really funny thing when it
comes to judaism where you've got
the anti-semitic right and white
nationalists who say jews are not white
jews are a different race i've had
richard spencer the white nationalist
tell me
jews are not european they're they're
not they're not what he is right jews
definitely are not white
among some on the left you have the view
that
jews are white with the white privilege
that comes with being white jews are not
minorities they're just privileged white
people and of course this is where the
concept of white passing comes up and
the truth is that
while ashkenazi jews
are absolutely white passing there's
lots of other jews uh sephardic jews
mizrahi jews who are not white passing
but that's not even really what this is
about
there's not one right answer but there
kind of is
if you take the view
that we're all one race there is no race
right like that's a view that some
people uh take now uh there's academic
circles where we're all just the human
race okay
if that's the case then this is all
meaningless right like if the view we're
taking is there's race is not a thing
ethnicity is not a thing then there's no
black people and there's no white people
and there's fine
if we accept that there are racial and
ethnic groups okay right so like if if
that's a conversa if we want to talk
about humans in that context jews are an
ethnic group
when i do my ancestry or 23 and me or
whatever it says oh your ethnicity is
100 ashkenazi jewish if i convert to
christianity religiously
i'm still 100 ashkenazi jewish and the
origin
of this confusion is that jews are an
ethno-religious group
now sometimes people like to say that's
a special pleading there's no other
ethno-religious group it's made up no
actually there's tons of ethno-religious
groups you're just not familiar with
them
the copts in egypt are an
ethno-religious group
the yazidi people of iraq are an
ethno-religious group which means what
yazidi iraqis are an ethnic group
and i hope i'm pronouncing this
correctly yazidism or yazidism is also a
religion
you can quit being a religious yazidi
you would still be ethnically yazidi you
might not have heard of that and so
sometimes people say no this is
something that's only it only exists
with jews it doesn't that's not true
separately
there are also
sort of bad faith people
who pretend not to understand this who
just like to attack jews as privileged
and not worthy of our consideration
despite being at the top when you look
at religiously based hate crimes in the
united states
jews are always either at the top or
almost there in terms of being the
victims of religiously oriented hate
crimes and sometimes the perceived
whiteness
of ashkenazi jews is used as a means to
write off anti-semitism and it was very
ugly it was done in a very ugly way
with the women's march of a couple years
ago
so um that is uh
whoopi goldberg is just wrong now in
terms of her being suspended i don't i
just don't know with all of these
suspects every time we talk about
suspensions i have no idea what's
appropriate or what's not
what i want to also mention is
the suspension of whoopi goldberg
is
uh furthering
anti-semitic tropes and you can you can
probably imagine why
whoopi goldberg suspended for her
comments
about the holocaust
is proof to those
who want to talk about
jewish control of media
to say
the jews got her the jews who control
hollywood and control the view
they got whoopi goldberg and it just for
so so i'm not saying the the suspension
is or isn't appropriate but
for people who want you know when all
you have is a hammer everything looks
like a nail and so the same people who
liked many of the same people who liked
whoopi's comments are now saying her
suspension is proof
of that conspiracy of jews to control
hollywood which we've talked about many
times before so another one of these
ugly incidents and i'm curious to hear
what you think about it
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20 off monk packs keto
nut and seed bars which taste just like
your favorite sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10 percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as i do they will
refund you all your money i think
there's a really good chance
monk pack nut and seed bars become your
favorite go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout